they'll fight for freedom wherever
there's trouble
g.i joe is there g.i
g.i joe's there gi joe retaliation so gi
joe retaliation is a sequel that
probably should have been a reboot but
it's a sequel to gi joe the rise of
cobra directed by stephen summers and if
you remember that was one of
the first i think it was the third video
i ever did third or fourth wasn't a fan
just wasn't a fan of that movie it was a
cheese fest i get that it's supposed to
be fun and based off a cartoon certainly
could have been better though but now we
have gi joe retaliation directed by a
different guys not directed by stephen
summers and you could totally see and
feel that in this movie so gi joe
retaliation stars the rock more or less
stars the rock he has
a couple people behind him but it's the
rock and if you remember at the end of
gi joe rise of cobra the president's now
an imposter he's not really the
president he's the mummy and now the
president orders the eradication of the
gi joes and now the rock lady j
who's who's hot and some other dude
who's not channing tatum
now have to save the world and then
snake eyes is doing his thing with storm
shadow who i
swore was dead in the first movie they
were like come on the storm shadow would
we gotta have him in the stake what
snake eye is going to do except be
awesome if storm shadow's not in it and
now we have a gi joe movie that's more
like the gi joe movie i wanted to see
the first time it still
isn't really perfect i'm not asking a gi
joe movie to be perfect but at least be
a great gi joe movie this movie is
enjoyable it's popcorn fun you have the
cobras who have now taken control of the
white house but not in that
olympus has fallen kind of way although
they do have a thing called zeus
apparently olympus is a big thing this
year when it comes to the white house
the movie a lot better than gi joe
retaliation still does have its problems
first of all the movie slows down
halfway through the movie you're like
all right yeah sweet popcorn movie it's
g.i joe it's all cool things are blowing
up then the movie slows down but not in
that story based kind of way
in that messy convoluted kind of way the
rock has to find out what's going on
then it goes over to snake eyes who's
separated from the joe's but he's on his
own quest
everyone seems separated and you're like
hey hey focus focus all of this is
happening because they had to force
storm shadow in the movie to give snake
eyes relevance if that didn't happen i
would argue that the movie would
actually be better as a whole
other than the fact that lady j is hot
as hell in this movie they have this guy
who's just
he's a guy what has he done what did he
do in this movie he could have saved the
entire
world i still would not be able to tell
you exactly what this guy did he's that
forgettable and at that point i argue
that it should have just been channing
tatum playing duke again at least we're
kind of attached to him at this point
and channing tatum as an actor has grown
so why not which
yeah this movie was postponed like over
half a year they said it was to convert
it into 3d which i argue
really or it was to put a couple new
scenes with channing tatum in the movie
in which he still gets written out of
the movie pretty early on and the
converted 3d is pretty useless now that
it's bad it's not like clash of the
titans where it hurts your eyes it's
just
almost unnoticeable just makes you
question you're like why did this all
happen
from an objective point of view i just
argued that the male character in the
movie that's not the rock should have
been duke cobra commander's pretty cool
in the movie
the other cobra commander in the other
movie wasn't cobra commander and even
when he became cobra commander you're
like that's not cobra commander at least
this time around he looks like cobra
commander he talks like cobra commander
he acts like cobra commander he's cobra
commander destro's not in the movie at
all
why i don't know destro has always been
a really cool gi joe character to me
even if he is just there to stand next
to cobra commander it would have been
cool to have him in the movie that's
pretty much what he did in the cartoon
anyway just stood there with his metal
head and you're like he's cool he has a
metal head he's like zordon with a body
how was that not awesome the story based
moments in the movie the story arcs seem
a little forced at times the movie
itself seems messy and kind of choppy
then they throw explosions at you in
action scenes to make you forget all
that which you do while it's happening
bruce willis was fine in the movie but
again you feel like they just brought
bruce willis on for the sake of bruce
willis being in this movie they're like
we need someone
bruce come on the movie's a lot more
down to earth and that's what i wanted
to see in the first movies they don't
have those
weird mega man outfits the gi joe bass
isn't some underground technodrome bass
that you have to use the modules from
ninja turtles to get to
it's a bass that's on the surface i can
conveniently get wiped out now i'll say
the movie is enjoyable enough but i'm
not gonna go out there to see it again i
think what's gonna happen with this
movie is called rule of contrast
know that phrase what rule of contrast
is is things might not be so bad when
they're first compared to something
that's worse for example you go to the
car dealership they show you the 25 000
car first and you're like i don't know
about the 25 000 car and they're like
well we do have this 20
000 car you're like oh that's 5 000
cheaper i'll take that
if they opened with the 20 000 car you
wouldn't have bought anything see what i
mean rule of contrast that's what gi joe
retaliation is
because the movie is going to be
compared in the minds of people to gi
joe the rise of cobra which was not good
gi joe retaliation is going to seem a
lot better than it actually is so is the
movie enjoyable yes in that simple
popcorn flick kind of way
is gi joe retaliation good well when
compared to gi joe the rise of cobra yes
as a movie in and of itself it's
enjoyable but i don't care if i ever see
it again so that kind of speaks for
itself but gi joe retaliation as a whole
i would say would probably be a good
time if you're drunk
yeah now it's a party real american hero
america but i do say that as a positive
it's like yeah it'd be fun if you're
drunk
not like it's funny if you're drunk
maybe if you're gonna see it see it at
matinee that's what i'm saying alright
so have you seen gi joe retaliation
what's your favorite gi joe character of
all time we're talking
anything everything any lore whatsoever
comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click
right here to see more